was genau und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ich habe mir natürlich
jedes gut wir befinden uns heute mal
wieder in mein büro
ich habe mich was kleines neues bestellt
auf den bund eines zuschauers der hat
mir das geschickt und ich dachte mir
man kann das mal wieder ausprobieren ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen dass ich jetzt
nicht so die krassesten erwartungen habe
ich erinnere mich da nämlich an meinen
real unboxing ja da habe ich durch drei
pakete für den zusammen 80 90 euro
bestellt und da war wirklich einfach
stumpf drei mal das gleiche drin und nur
möbel trotzdem haben wir hier heute zwei
pakete bestellt von kaufen also kauf
land.de das ist auch eine seite da
können glaube ich auch andere händler
sachen übertreiben ich werde euch das
super gerne hier mal ein ich habe 50
euro pro paket bezahlt und da so 100
euro warenwert drin sein was das für
waren sind kein plan ob das jetzt
irgendwas außen kaufen und sortiment ist
oder von irgendetwas anderem ich weiß
nicht mal das hier ist jetzt das erste
paket man muss ja auch sagen ich
beziehungsweise auch ihr seid schon ein
bisschen verwöhnt gerade wenn ich an
meine 3000 euro saturn wolfs vom
vorletzten video denke da sind dann halt
wirklich kranke sachen drin hier das ist
dann wieder das holt uns alle wieder ein
bisschen glaube ich auf dem boden der
tatsachen zurück
nichtsdestotrotz kann ich auch schon mal
ankündigen dass ich nach langem suchen
ein händler gefunden habe von dem ich
deutsche amazon restposten abkaufen kann
das war allerdings muss man ganz ehrlich
sagen auch alles andere als leicht weil
ich habe erfahren dass amazon
deutschland die west post oder retouren
nicht wieder nach deutschland verkauft
sondern ins ausland warum weiß ich nicht
ganz genau das vermisse ich im auto
heraus aber dann müssen wir aus dem
ausland wie die optionen nach
deutschland und so eine palette habe ich
bestellt über 1000 euro das wird auch
will deswegen als 90 auf jeden fall den
kanal zu abonnieren start nochmal hier
nicht was ist das denn
wer was für marie oder das ist auf jeden
fall sehr heiß keine ahnung warum das in
unserem paket landet darum will dass wir
keine haben
doch klasse aus platz immer halt ich
mache weiter mit der nächsten sachen ich
glaube wir hatten im real paket auch so
was ist das denn ein schal also das ist
auf jeden fall keine hochwertiger schal
fühlt sich nicht so gut an könnte auch
von von von muss sein nicht auch ein
bisschen so gut
das lege ich mal schnell zur seite die
angebetete erstmal was haben die das ist
sind hier drin
sexy christus hier haben wir einen ein t
shirt von superman kindergröße in excess
da finde ich bestimmt jemanden wähle ich
das schenken kann das hier sieht aus als
wären das oder also ich hab schon mal
sagen es ist deutlich besser als die
real pakete kommen wirklich schuhe drin
aber ich habe halt auch ein bisschen
mehr geld bezahlt für eine kiste hh ach
du scheiße also wovon wenn jemand völlig
hat aber da verstehe ich dass sie keiner
kaufen will kann man hier vorne was da
drauf der sex pistols alter junge also
mit denen schon bist du auf jeden fall
keine sex pistols würde ich mal sagen
das wäre jetzt auch sehr krass gewesen
wären da irgendwelche adidas mika oder
so drin
wir haben ja einfach einen helm
aber dass so ein helm habe ich noch nie
gesehen also ich denke mal das ist ganz
und du bist ein ganz normaler
fahrradhelm
allerdings so an ritter angelehnten
kommen also sowieso schon so ein
ritterhelm mittelalter helm ist das
glaube ich weiß nicht
schön schnellstmöglich wieder absetzen
die haben wir noch ein zweiter fall das
ist eigentlich denke ich mal so ein
gleicher schal wie dieser schwarzen oder
einer anderen farbe ungefähr kommen wir
zum nächsten paket hier haben wir eine
vielleicht ist eine tasse drin oder so
das könnte ich mir gut vorstellen
aber okay hier ach soooo ich verstehe
wir haben hier ein teelicht ja das
zündet man an und stirbt dann die lampe
viel druck also ich hab da mal von herrn
aus den kanälen absetzen kann man
perfekt und einfach angst und mit dem
lucky donkey mini-usb feuerzeug zum
aufladen man drückt hier drauf das
dingen geht an und ihr könnt die kerze
anzünden
dann macht man das wieder zu kostet auch
nur 9 euro 919 check meinen shop ab
jetzt müsste es nur noch dunkel sein
dann seht dass wir schon gut aus ich
kann nur leider mein büro hier nicht
dunkel machen also die begeisterung hält
sich weiter in grenzen ich dachte gerade
die haben ja einen louis vitton
portemonnaie aber da habe ich mich dann
habe ich mich dann doch bergkristall
piraten hose xl kann nicht perfekt
benutzen wenn ich das nächste mal
karneval hier
wobei das nächstes jahr wahrscheinlich
heiß nicht gucken mal meine dafür kann
man das verwenden der rest ich will das
mal eben aus hier ist halt wirklich nur
noch schrott drin also ich kann mir
schon vorstellen dass das aus einkauf
lang sortiment kommt allerdings ist das
auch schon so in die jahre gekommene
pink fresh himalaya dort lambretta die
haben wir eine chance und sonst nur so
kommt man doch dann haben wir noch
pacemark noch eindruck ein paar hh ein
playboy portemonnaie und ich glaube 2
schott gläser eine marihuana figur soll
das bob marley sein könnte hinkommen
kümmern und dann kannst du das muss ich
sagen
also ich bin jetzt zwar kein tipper aber
das feierlich weil du kannst hier in
dieser box dein gras autobahn
das muss ich mal kurz in den mußler kurs
mein freund schicken da finde ich auf
jeden fall abnehmer führen ok nein
drogen sind schlecht konsumiert keine
drogen
okay was haben wir hier noch den 8 also
war es ist schon
wir haben hier einen flachmann da kannst
du harten alkohol reintun und den dann
also sowas solche dinger finde ich schon
sehr an sich ich bin jetzt kein zug der
sowas benutzt aber es gibt ja viele die
damit um laufen und da ihren
jägermeister einschnitten oder mal hier
und hier haben eine gelbe tasse mit p
also ein bisschen gruselig ist diese
kiste ja schon oder dass du auf jeden
fall die erste jetzt wo wir noch die
zweite box mal gucken ob da was anderes
und es allen drucksachen wenig
ausgeprägt aber das ist nicht der
hässlichste rucksack den ich je gesehen
hat so dass hier ist die zweite kiste
die ist ein bisschen leichter aber auch
ein bisschen größer keine ahnung
wahrscheinlich ja also die erste hatte
finde ich auf jeden fall überhaupt
nichts mit 100 euro waren mehr zu tun so
wie sie eigentlich drauf stand an sich
war da noch so flohmarkt am strand
gepackt von alina alina hat das ganze
gefragt hab mal so plötzlichen die kann
ich sogar gebrauchen ohne scheiß für
meine wohnung ich hab so was also ich
hab so was nicht ich habe mir nämlich
letzten 90 gekauft und da werden wir so
klar ist schon ganz gut vor allem mit
mahlzeit drauf wunderschön
danke dafür dann haben wir hier noch
alter bierflasche im glas zweier set
brutal warum dann nicht gleich so damit
kann ich etwas anfangen so etwas habe
ich auch noch nie gesehen im glas ist
hier die form einer bierflasche und das
heißt du kannst sie da rein für ja oder
doch wahrscheinlich geht das sohn andré
ist das um geil erhalte ich auch dave
also ohne scheiß die platzherren die
biergläser und normale behaltet es kann
nur noch besser werden
was haben wir hier la petit prince der
kleine prinz ach so na ja für kinder
das ist so eine nachttischlampe auch
ganz schön ich glaube die da habe ich
einen abnehmer für die verschenkt dann
haben wir hier ohne urteil
und gleich noch ein brot also wäre das
jetzt eine schöne uhr könnte ich mir
auch vorstellen wie hier irgendwo
hinzubringen
aber ich weiß nicht so ganz schöne idee
schönau was ist das denn
gitta land mit chrome basic hier steht
drauf du nord open das stellt man hier
oben drüber
das kommt hier oben drauf dann stecken
wir da hinten mal ein
naja ich denke mal so könnte die die
fahrer wechseln wäre es bestimmt ganz
gut so ist es ein bisschen billig oder
haben wir hier noch eine fußmatte für
abbauen und wüstenrot ihren braucht
finde ich auch gar nicht mal so schlecht
hatte ich einen hund finde ich die auf
jeden fall brauchen also diese box wenn
du jetzt schon tausend mal besser als
die andere daran irgendwie nochmal
drehen dann haben wir hier noch so
sockets oder ja da kann es weiterhin die
dort leben wollen aufs armaturenbrett im
auto passen und hier noch einen tag und
das war es eigentlich der rest ist ja
kläger einsicht nun lisa flock also die
100 euro hätte ich auch genauso gut in
milch meisten gern aber gut leute das
war der hinweis eines zuschauers und ich
finde es auch manchmal cool dass danach
zu kaufen so ich sage ja auch immer wenn
ihr irgendwelche sachen habe ich
bestellen sollte schickt mir die auf
jeden fall über instagram da es sich
alex wie ansonsten werde ich zwei von
diesen paketen neu packen mit den
gleichen sachen drin und die an jemand
von euch raus zügen ihr müssen wir den
versand bezahlen könnt ihr sehr gern
abchecken
ich hoffe es in der video beschleunigung
verlinkt das war's schon ich verspreche
euch das nächste an boxen wird wieder
viel bilder und da freue ich mich schon
sehr drauf abonniert den kanalbau drei
leute danke fürs zuschauen